Speaker 1: Okay. Let's look at a couple of clips.
You know, something kind of interesting has
started happening over roughly, I'd say, the last
3 to 4 weeks. And it relates to this guy, Mike
Lindell, the CEO of Mypillow, a right wing pillow
manufacturer who became friendly with Trump early
in the pandemic, started showing up about how he's
going to be making masks and all these things.
I don't know that they ever made any masks, but
really since the election pillow as we know him,
pillows goal has been to overturn
the election results, insisting
dozens of times that we're just days away. We're
weeks away, maybe at the most, a few months away
from blockbuster evidence coming out and just
overturning everything. And there, you know,
he claims that they're suing all machines.
Speaker 3: We're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: All of my coffee machines
are now in witness protection
as a result of that. So anyway,
this this thing has happened where clearly pillow
is a laughing stock and we all recognize that.
But over the last 3 to 4 weeks for me and I
know also for some people in the audience,
it started to get almost a little bit sad where
the guy seems kind of genuinely unwell in a way.
And we know he has a background of drug addiction
in his past and generally speaking, it from things
that he said we're putting together that he seems
to really believe this crazy election stuff.
He is spending a ton of money and not even really
seeing his family going all around the country
pushing it. And I and some others in the audience
have started to wonder whether this is kind of
becoming almost more medical in nature in some
way. And then all of a sudden, over the weekend,
Pillow spoke at the experience, the Reawakening
Reawaken America tour. This is the event where,
like Eric Trump will often speak at it. And
sometimes I think Ted Nugent has spoken. We're
going to look at some Eric Trump clips a little
bit later. And pillow now seems to have a very bad
hand tremor. So I'm going to play this clip for
you. It is visual. You sort of hear the tremor in
his voice a little bit. But really what you have
to see as he starts switching the mic from hand
to hand, because the mic itself is shaking. And a
lot of people emailed me about this. And listen,
I mean, something does seem to be going
on with the guy. Let's take a look.
Speaker 3: Thank you all. You guys
keep me going, and I'll tell you that
we're not giving up anything ever.
Speaker 1: So there you can see in the left hand,
this is the key moment where the hand is just
very, very shaky when the mic is in this hand. But
and then he seems to recognize it
and change the mic to the other hand.
Speaker 3: So they are.
Speaker 1: And it still.
Speaker 3: Shouldn't be what he was or what he
was talking about there on I Pray for everyone.
He was just talking about them. There was the
interview over next door and the guy all of a
sudden they're interviewing and I'm trying to
tell them what's going to happen, like I do
all the media. And once again, he took it down a
road here and made it about something it wasn't.
And I ended the interview very abruptly.
Speaker 1: Now, I understand that what he's saying
also does it's just completely incoherent.
Speaker 3:
And it wasn't. And you guys
got to realize, Norman, that.
Speaker 1: That hand is just all over the.
Speaker 3: Place. I don't do that. But I had
to get out here to speak. Normally, I would sit
there on the phone with the media for an hour,
hours at a time you could call. I have every media
outlet, I think, in my pocket from Jim Acosta to
The Daily Beast.
Speaker 1: So anyway,
it's it's something seems to be going on here.
There seems to be some kind of spiral happening.
And it is getting kind of sad. I mean, he has
prior drug issues. We don't know anything about
what's going on right now. Who knows what it
could be? And this isn't to make fun of a medical
condition or a drug addiction. If either or both
are factors, it's a reminder that this guy who
has been saying outrageous and untrue things
for over a year now about the 2020 election,
corrosive, spending, his money in a way that is
corrosive to democracy making, also throwing all
sorts of innocent victims under the bus. And we'll
talk on the bonus show today about how his count
countersuits against the voting machine companies
have been thrown out. He's been doing a lot of
damage and he might genuinely be unwell. It's not
an excuse for his behavior, but there's something
sad about watching him. He does seem to genuinely
believe what he's saying. And one one wonders,
are there friends and family here that could
stage some kind of an intervention? Because,
quite frankly, this doesn't seem to be good for
him. It doesn't seem to be good for his family,
which he claims he doesn't see anymore. And it's
certainly not good for the country. One other clip
I want to play from from pillow from over
the weekend. This was at a different event.
He is also claiming that the January
six Trump riots were a setup by the
left to deplatform Trump and his supporters
from social media and that it's basically
becoming Nazi Germany. Here, take a look.
Speaker 3: Then they took him back because
they had a safety net and what was out,
that was January six. They had that all
set up so that what would happen would be a
historic day in history, which was January 7th.
And on January 7th is the day they tried to
take our voice forever. They tried to turn
out the lights on all of your voices. 1.2 million
Americans for De-Platforming, including our great
president, Donald Trump on Vimeo, YouTube, sucker
bucks, Facebook, Twitter, Vimeo, you name it. All
these platforms where you canceled. Well, that was
a day, that day. And it put fear into everyone.
It was just like Nazi Germany, where everybody
either had fear or you said over here and you
didn't want to talk about it. You know, you didn't
want to talk out of fear. And everybody, you know.
Speaker 1: When the Trump rioters committed
all that violence and destruction of property
and then Trump was banned from Twitter, it
didn't strike me like Nazi Germany. And I'm
curious how many of you say, you know, but the
first thing my mind went to was Nazi Germany?
I don't think so. And you might have
noticed, oh, this is an interesting detail
in the background. You might see that there a bus
and on the side it says Jesus, guns and babies,
Jesus, guns and babies. And this was at a campaign
in Forsyth, Georgia, for some of the upcoming
elections happening there. This is obviously
very sad when it comes to pillow himself,
but we can't ignore that there's a extraordinarily
dangerous movement here. And so when we when we
talk about these issues, we want to find kind
of a reasonable medium where we don't say
this is just political disagreement with people
who are completely of sound mind because many
of them don't appear to be of sound mind.
On the other hand, we can't say this is
merely a mental health issue. Most people who have
mental health issues don't do any of this stuff.
And so we're trying to craft a more accurate but
also empathetic narrative about what is a really
scary and unhinged movement that is sadly much
bigger than any of us would like to admit. But
we have to be accurate and we have to admit it's
a pretty big movement here in the United States.